digamos que tengo dos números en una
recta numérica vamos a dibujar la recta
la dibujamos así y los dos números en mi
recta numérica
son los números representados por la
letra a y la letra b y la forma en que
lo he dibujado es que b está a la
derecha de a y por convención la letra b
va a ser más grande que la letrada y
digamos que quiero conocer la distancia
entre a y b cuál es la distancia que hay
entre a y b cómo puedo encontrar esto
puedo tomar el número más grande de
estos dos que va a ser b y restarle el
número más pequeño que es a y me voy a
quedar con esta distancia de aquí esto
me va a dar un valor positivo y cuando
hablamos de distancias siempre nos
interesa obtener un valor positivo pues
es que tan lejos se encuentran estas dos
cosas pero pude definir que voy a restar
ve - am porque aquí yo sé que va a ser
más grande que a y esto me dará un
resultado positivo qué tal si yo supiera
que a es mayor que b pues a día lo
opuesto vamos a dibujar
la recta numérica la voy a poner aquí
en este caso os voy a hacer que no sea
mayor que ver esto es ve aquí está
y si quiero calcular la distancia entre
veía esto de acá ahora voy a tomar el
mayor de estos dos que es a pues
recuerden que queremos la distancia
positiva y le voy a restar el más
pequeño que es b y bueno aquí tengo ve -
ah y aquí tengo a menos b pero qué tal
si yo no sé cuál de estos números es más
grande yo no sé si el más grandes pues
ve que puedo hacer en este caso pues lo
que podemos hacer es tomar ya sea a
menos b&b menos y tomar el valor
absoluto y si lo hacemos así no va a
importar si usamos ve menos oa menos ve
resulta que sin importar si b es mayor
que a o a es mayor que ve el valor
absoluto de a menos b es equivalente o
igual al valor absoluto debe menos a y
cualquiera de estas dos expresiones es
igual a la distancia entre 2
números yo aquí los invito a que jueguen
con los signos y traten de factorizar el
menos y pensar sobre el valor absoluto y
ustedes verán porque esto tiene sentido
en otro vídeo haré una justificación un
poco más rigurosa de por qué esto se
cumple pero lo importante para este
vídeo es ver si esto es verdadero veamos
algunos ejemplos y aquí ya tengo
preparada una recta numérica imaginemos
que quiero encontrar la distancia entre
digamos menos 2
3 positivos
pues podemos ver la recta numérica para
encontrar esta distancia si partimos de
menos 2 hacia 3 positivo
veremos que son 1 2 3 4 5
esta distancia de aquí es igual a 5
tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 incluso podemos
recorrer estos 5 hacia atrás de 3 a -2
pero veamos si lo que escribí aquí
aplica a este ejemplo si tomamos nuestro
menos 2 como a y el 3 como ve podemos
escribir a esto como el valor absoluto
de menos 2 - 3
- 3
a que va a ser igual esto pues va a ser
igual a menos dos menos tres es menos
cinco por lo que va a ser igual al valor
absoluto de menos cinco y esto es igual
a cinco noten que yo reste el número más
grande al número pequeño tengo un valor
negativo pero estoy tomando el valor
absoluto lo que me da la distancia real
entre estos dos números y qué tal si lo
hago al revés voy a tomar aquí 3 el
valor absoluto de 3 - y entre paréntesis
pongo menos 2
3 - menos 2 si restamos el número
pequeño del número más grande deberemos
tener un valor positivo y aquí el valor
positivo es extra realmente no lo
necesitamos pero vamos a verificar que
es cierto esto es 3 menos menos 2 que es
lo mismo que tres más 25 así que será el
valor absoluto de 5 el cual es por
supuesto igual a 5 y espero que con
estos recuerden que si necesitan conocer
la distancia entre dos números pueden
restar un número al otro número y no
importa cual restemos de cual 3 - menos
2 o menos 2 menos tres sólo hay que
tener cuidado aquí con los signos
negativos simplemente tomamos el valor
absoluto de esto y obtendremos la
distancia entre estos dos números esto
es algo muy importante ya que más
adelante durante su estudio de las
matemáticas llegará un momento en el que
su maestro de matemáticas les pida la
distancia entre dos números
representadas con las letras a yb
por ejemplo entonces la distancia entre
a y b es el valor absoluto de a menos b
y también lo puedo escribir así lo
importante es darnos cuenta que estas
dos cosas son lo mismo nos van a dar
exactamente el mismo valor y ambas
representan la distancia entre estos dos
números